à paris le père noël a élu domicile sur
la place du tertre à montmartre il
reçoit jusqu'à demain dans son chalet
les enfants sages et les moins sages
comme william irigoyen et bernard
connors qui ont plaidé leur cause
avant la grande distribution des cadeaux
la plupart des lettres ont une taille
normale mais certains enfants c'est bien
connu voit tout en grand et ont
tellement de choses à dire au père noël
que même un format 3 ne suffit plus sur
la place du tertre à paris des peintres
postmoderniste vient exercer leurs
talents ici l'enfant est roi libre de
dessiner ce que bon lui semble
ou de pinceau coup de crayon mathias lui
est venue après avoir écrit sa lettre à
mais c'est magnifique picasso jusqu'à
demain soir le père noël fait une halte
bien méritée à montmartre avant de
reprendre son traîneau avec ses copains
il est venu distraire les enfants
au programme fabrication de jouets
échange standard
bisous contre cadeaux sans oublier
l'éternel spectacle de marionnettes les
yeux brillent d'ici peu antoine îles et
les autres s'endormiront tranquillement
se disant que le grand soir c'est pour
bientôt
finalement le père noël est bien le seul
à travailler d'arrache-pied durant ses
vacances à répéter inlassablement les
mêmes choses à ceux qui le dévore des
yeux du moins les téméraires qui osent
l'approcher
la galite si vous apporte des cadeaux
mais moi j'ai pas besoin de cadeaux rien
que le sourire des enfants ça ne suffit
allez encore 24 heures à attendre et
vous pourrez enfin dire et tu es un vrai
père noël